[Music]  something is horribly wrong in the magic  realm  and it seems like  damien wayne might actually be the cause  of this somehow  [Music]  zatanna is obviously a big part of issue  one constantine the demon felix faust  tanorak you're going to be seeing  as many of the magic characters as as we  have in the decent universe with batman  superman world's finest we've made no  secret that the devil nazar who was the  villain there is also going to be one of  the big villains in batman versus robin  my mood is great the character  likenesses her bang on the way he  handles batman is terrific he takes  advantage of the real estate that i give  him and he doesn't squawk when i shovel  just gobs and gobs of magical artifact  reference at him batman versus robin  eyes very strongly into the future of  the dc universe there's something that  happens in the climax that will affect  dozens and dozens of dc characters minor  and major  [Music]  you